anh alo
[âm nhạc]
ừ ừ
anh ạ
Vì sao màn cho lên à ok alo
ờ ờ Chào tất cả bạn
à à
ừ ừ
À
hôm nay là tiền đến tiếng Anh
được hôm nay bắt đầu từ hôm nay tôi sẽ
sẽ dạy các bạn hết bằng tiếng Anh đối
ngoại
khác ngoài dạy bằng tiếng Anh nhưng mà
đặt tên biến đặt tên mọi thứ tự tên bạn
đã thử mọi thứ sẽ bằng tiếng Anh đều họa
thì cho các bạn
được à
Ông Bà mình mình hôm nay thật ra dạy
xanh CRD là một cái thứ rất là như anh
rỡ nhanh ấy nhưng mà Bởi vì trên trên
lớp thì mình sẽ dạy cho các bạn từ từ
một từ từ từng bước một nhưng mà Bởi vì
các bạn mình mình thấy các bạn cũng hiểu
qua về M với Seo Ok mình dậy khám vài
buổi rồi các hợp việc là các bạn là xem
xong rồi Các bạn có thể thực hành luôn
còn nếu mà mình dạy trên lớp thì mình
phải dậy từ từ thì mình thích đây mình
sự cho các bạn xem thử tài liệu phải
giáo án mình đã từng dậy nay mình sẽ cho
các bạn xem thử đã nhá xem cái giáo án
mình đã tự tự soạn và từng dậy thì nó sẽ
là như thế nào là ram này đợi tôi một tí
ăn cơm ở trong bé ông xem luôn này thì
ông sẽ thấy là tối ở đây tôi soạn ra nó
khá là đơn giản và và kiểu Từng Bùi từ
buổi như thế nào Nhưng thực tế là hôm
nay mình sẽ không dậy được mình sẽ không
học chậm như thế
có ai bởi bột nhé bởi một là chỉ giới
thiệu này
ý là không phải bởi một mà từng từng cái
từng cái như nào giới thiệu qua ngay này
như cái 2 dòng này nghỉ hay Trang mà tại
sao chị nhắn đấy Cái ảnh tôi vứt bay đâu
đấy
Thứ
hai này dâu tinh này
Ừ hình như là cái này của tôi bị bay mất
cái ảnh đấy
nói cho Protein là sẽ Chị nói qua router
có thứ thứ
anh đợi công tí Hình như là à Cái
wordpad này của tôi nó bị lỗi rồi thể mở
bằng Notepad thì nó sẽ không hiển thị ra
hết được rồi tôi tình thì nhé Tôi sẽ mở
cái này bằng à
ờ ờ ờ
anh không tải đâu nha
à à
thì
tôi luôn kiểm tra lại xem nó nằm có nằm
trong thư mục cái không nằm Nếu không
nằm trong thư mục vệ phải
khi extract là một thư mục Như Lai
ở
cổng cách nhanh chúng ta sẽ đây hết toàn
bộ cái này lên a
Drive Đợi gì ngoài tôi không nhạy cảm
thì à
anh đã không còn nhạy cảm lắm rồi anh em
à
anh không nên cho xem nỡ lại có gì hỏi
định cả
video này còn đang được quay lại nữa à
có một web để lưu trữ sách cần server
không ạ một cái gì bất kỳ cái gì cũng
phải cần server chứ Thì nó chạy cái web
chứ
xe tải tôi sẽ đẩy lên dai nó có thể đọc
anh đọc gồm tất cả file qua cua gái hỗ
trợ đọc của thằng Google luôn
xe tải tại nó có 23 tranh như này cơ mà
chứ không phải vừa rồi nó bị kế wed nó
tắt rồi lỗi
Mỹ
Tâm người tôi chưa biết câm vì sau các
bạn làm thì các bạn phải nhớ là căn nó
là căn kiểu trước khi file nữa nhé 2 để
cắt mà như này chứ không phải kiểu trông
như này về tôi chưa biết căm được đấy
xin lỗi chồng tệ quá đây tôi nhớ có cái
ảnh này cái ảnh hôm trước tôi từng áp
dụng với ông rồi
hả là bé alo alo lo toan chưa alo
ở nhà to quá mức phải nó Nam báo đỏ đấy
anh alo
anh alo alo alo ờ ờ
giờ toàn chưa
Ừ ok
xe Vision ta
cái này tôi tự soạn mà Nên rất khả năng
được sai thì lại càng chứng minh việc cả
tôi tự soạn cái này không tắm Giữ à Tại
sao ở đấy mình làm này trái nhỉ
Ừ Kệ đi Nói chung ở đây tôi làm này cậu
ngay đây bài 1 này 12 này
ờ ờ 72 protein
Em
học khóa này bao lâu thì làm được đi làm
được Đã Kết Thúc Kháng này Thôi kết thúc
là này bạn các bạn thì đi làm rồi
với kết quả này là bao gồm làm tại đồ ăn
nhé
ở đây đây đây tôi làm cũng ngồi thi công
làm cái này cái này là tôi phải phải
dùng cái để mạnh đây mấy ông thấy không
phải xuống ngồi soạn xong rồi tôi phải
tô màu cho từng cái cho nó dễ nhìn một
hồi tôi làm cái đoạn Tài liệu này vất
mãi vì kiểu muốn cho nó dễ nhìn thấy này
có thử thứ cái này trông trên Dock này
xấu thế này thôi còn trên trên kẹo Bởi
tôi xuất cái này ra pdf mà trong suốt
pdf nó đẹp hơn không phải tin tôi không
chung thời Tôi làm nó một bài Rôti ngày
mà bài container 1 bài view cái thứ thứ
Blast này máy quét này rồi nhờ song sinh
À
Ừ nhưng mà tôi sẽ không dậy theo kiểu gì
nữa tôi sẽ tôi sẽ làm như sau tôi sẽ
không dậy Bởi vì thực là tôi thấy mấy
cái buổi này nó hơi sai sai này chúng ta
phải nhảy sang xe lu D trước đây là quần
trước Tuy nhiên là tôi sẽ tạm bỏ qua cho
các bạn về quay do Hồi đấy tôi dậy ở
sinh viên là tôi muốn dạy cho sinh viên
nhớ lại là cả cậu esquare nên tôi dậy
Các bạn thấy khái niệm quay do tất cả an
kìa vẫn ghi lại câu xvideo Nhưng mà thực
tế là mình thấy bây giờ là ít công ty
nào sử dụng TP thuần đưa người sang công
ty khác thì có thể không dùng mà không
dùng pp đỡ dùng ngôn ngữ khác thì nhưng
mà cũng không phải viết lại câu f-care
lặng nhiều đến thế nữa nên là mình nghĩ
là mình sẽ tạm bỏ qua các bạn việc ôn
lại nasware các bạn sẽ phải tự ôn lấy
que mình sẽ không không Ô nasware lại
các bạn nữa mà mình sẽ dùng những hàm có
sẵn để mà xử lý là mọi thao tác nhanh
nhem cửa hàng xăng ergen luôn nên là
nhiều bạn cũng sẽ thấy là tôi sẽ dạy nó
hơi bị chẳng sợ ngoài cả mày nói hàng để
trả lời ngay cả nhưng mà tôi đấy Đấy sau
sau vài năm kinh nghiệm dạy tôi tôi đúc
kết được như thế
không biết hiện tại tôi vẫn thấy có vẻ
sẽ được bây giờ bắt đầu từ bây giờ thì
tôi tôi tôi sẽ dạy theo kiểu một cái
sườn ngủ thôi nha xem mấy ông thấy bị
nhanh quá gì gì đó thì mày Ông cứ góp ý
nhé ok Nói chung à
đầu tiên là hôm nay tôi sẽ
tôi sẽ nói qua mấy cái thứ nhất là công
cụ hỗ trợ cho mấy ông người Việt Cốt đã
thì Ừ tôi sẽ có cái cái Pocket này
leveldb mất 3
Pocket này tác dụng vào gì nó sẽ hiển
thị ra cái à
ở đâu sao Pocket Philippines cái này
đang lại phải trả phí thấp nó sẽ đây
Ừ
cái này gọi không phải xem chi đâu nha
rồi đấy Cái này à
Ừ cái này nó sẽ hiển thị luôn Hiển thị
một cái ở dưới như thế này cái ba tất cả
cái hang ấy cái thành dùng cây thành
trên này nhờ một tuổi thai này nó sẽ ở
dưới thì cái hai ngày có tác dụng và
hiển thị ra kiểu rất nhiều rất nhiều thứ
mấy ông cần xem từ điển hình là từ những
câu truy vấn như thế nào sau đó áp dụng
những cái view gì đang biết gì trong
cách 2 trong xứ Xuân đang có những cái
gì cậu hết tất cả đây nên làm Nếu chỉ
cần cài cái này có vẫn chưa đầy đủ đây
tôi sẽ chạy câu lệnh này bằng cách là
nhóm trước tôi bảo là mình sẽ có cmd nằm
trong cái thư mục và cốt của mình không
ạ rồi chạy cái này là xong nó sẽ tải về
tôi chưa tay
tại nhanh thôi ạ bác sĩ mạng xịn
ờ ờ tiếp theo là còn thêm cả t-sport kệ
ID hepl nhưng mà tôi sẽ xin phép là khi
nào dùng đến thì thôi dễ
Ừ chị mà ông sao t stop thì tôi thường
ai dùng mà do bởi vì công ty tôi không
không có không dùng view nữa nên là
không bao giờ hình nhìn thấy cái đi bốc
3 nên là người dùng t-stop Nhưng mà nếu
mà Mấy ông cày đi bước 3 rồi tôi thấy tớ
có cũng chẳng cần cài nữa còn cái này
cái khác cái này để hỗ trợ cho IDE tất
cả các pantone đọc vào gợi ý cho ông cốt
được ấy thì cái này phải về sau mấy ông
ấy lên cài để không ạ tiếp theo và tôi
chỉ cho mấy phím tắt của cái cmd tôi
đang dùng bởi vì a nhưng mà Ông thấy là
bây giờ mình tôi sẽ phải luôn mở cái cái
cmd này để tôi tí nó chạy những câu lệnh
thì
Hà selling Price đã cái link Bright vừa
làm em thử ra nó lạc hậu rồi nghe tội
không muốn chia sẻ với ông chứ không
phải là tôi giữ làm gì cả đang cả là bây
giờ tôi sẽ dạy theo kiểu cái sườn khác
nên này ra cái đấy nó đúng nhiều dạng mà
không áp dụng nữa thôi vừa rồi chỉ cho
các bạn xem qua để các bạn hình dung Ừ
Tôi đã từng làm giáo án và tài liệu như
nào nhưng tôi cảm thấy đứa nó không phù
hợp nữa này thôi
chứ nếu mà nhiều nhiều người mà tôi từng
biết đấy là người ta kiểu lười nói thẳng
là người ta kiểu lười thay đổi và người
ta kiểu không nghĩ hẳn nó sinh viên làm
đâu Nói hẳn như thế ví dụ là sử tôi Soạn
giáo án ở ngoài năm nào năm nào tôi cũng
Copy lại đúng người giao hàng đấy tôi
dậy cho mấy ông cứ thể dạy cho mấy ông
những cái ngôn ngữ cổ hẳn rồi vì tôi
quen thuộc với nó tôi có thể làm thế mà
đúng không Nhưng mà tôi thấy rằng nó Tôi
sẽ không làm thế với vì tôi nghị nghĩ là
sinh viên mình mình phải thay đổi thay
đổi công nghệ Thay đổi là mình phải thay
đổi theo là mình phải dậy sinh viên theo
đúng cái đấy chứ mình không Nôi lại giáo
án cũ để mà dậy Không dậy Không phải
thấy là nó sai rồi kệ mà Tôi thấy kiểu
mà sai nó có vấn đề gì đó rồi tôi phải
tìm cách tới đây rồi hết toàn bộ tôi cái
này xã mấy ông thấy vừa tôi Thực ra tôi
bố mẹ tôi lấy cái tài liệu da cơ tôi tôi
xóa tôi xóa các tài liệu từ lâu lắm rồi
nay vào tiện hệ tôi cũng nói luôn cái vụ
đấy cũng ở đây luôn này thì có nhiều có
vài bạn đã hỏi tôi anh nhận Thảo lao
chín rồi à khẳng định là không Tôi Chính
xác là tôi hồi mà tôi đi làm ở Hồi đấy
rất lâu rồi mà tôi dùng Lazio 5.6 có đấy
tôi khá là không phải 5.655 thôi
155 mấy đấy Sau đó thì
sang công ty mới này gần đây thì tôi mới
được dùng xanh level 8 thì ở công ty tôi
vẫn đang dùng live tám Bởi vì bởi vì nó
tp7 còn nếu muốn sang level 9 thì phải
Lâm p mà việc nông lên hẳn cái ngưỡng
như thế là thay đổi lẫn nhiều nên thành
ra là còn gì thôi cho 5 và thế là thức
ra cái việc mà động và lao chín ở gần
nhiều tôi gần đây tôi mới động vào một
hai lần thì mà tôi cài trên máy nên là
sẽ có rất nhiều cái mà có thể là tôi
Thảo ở bên ra 8 chết nó sẽ Nó sẽ thay
đổi một tí ở ra cho chín thường là nó
không thay đổi nhiều lắm đâu Nó vẫn giữ
nguyên cái cũ chẳng qua nó thêm nhiều
cái mới thì thì nói chung là tôi sẽ
nhưng mà tôi không thể tôi không thể
rảnh mời ông về lao 8 được bởi vì sao
Bởi vì à
anh Bởi vì à mình lên như tôi nói mình
lên kẻo chạy theo công nghệ cái mới chứ
Chúng ta không nên kiểu chạy theo cái cũ
anh nói thế nhưng mà nhưng mà nhiều công
ty đưa vẫn đang dùng lao ra 8 Thì anh
cũng nói gì tôi rằng ạ nghĩa đã làm rồi
thì không khóm à nâng lên được nên nó
vẫn dùng là 8 nên là mấy Âu Cơ cân nhắc
nhá thì không có vẻ cân nhắc việc là một
là em em vào hàng những công ty mới hạn
thì họ sẽ dùng những cái mới giống như
P8 có cả chí còn nếu là mấy ông vào mấy
công ty mà đã chạy cầm hai ba năm rồi
thì chắc chắn là họ sẽ dùng cái phiên
bản cũ đã leo 800 đương nhiên là tôi sẽ
không dạy mày ông cái gì mà mới hoàn
toàn đâu
em nghe nói chung là mấy ông cứ cân nhắc
rồi vội đấy nhé
à à
Ê mấy ông có gì mày không đặt đặt có hỏi
Bây giờ tôi xin phép Chắc là để cuối bội
tôi trả lời nhé tôi Cha tôi nói qua mấy
nay tôi dậy là đúng rồi Tiếp theo là có
vài bạn tôi không Tôi không biết được
mấy hôm trước mấy ông có bị cài đặt có
vấn đề gì không Nhưng mà cài đặt mình
cái kakuro thì có không nách lệch
không đáng lấy finney được với nó có
thêm cái đoạn mà chọn phiên bản VP chị
Mời ông vào bên A
Ê mày không vào bên ww này à lâu vào
ragone lại và pin này xô ngồi và pp xong
rồi chọn vào trong thư mục đấy Sao rồi
chọn là trên pp nhá
TP chấm exo-k Lúc này nó chỉ có một cái
thôi à
Ê bà như tôi nói là mấy ông mặc định
level này sẽ có à mặc định lagon để nó
sẽ có phiên bản
t740 ông một quan hệ dùng nó hay ở như
tôm trước và tôi Tại thêm TP 8.1 này để
mà nếu mà tải 8.1 thì sẽ và và cài đặt
được song ca Maurer rồi chạy của brother
để mà tạo thì sẽ tạo được da level 99 nó
sẽ cài 9 còn nếu mà ông dùng cái 7.4 này
ông cài thì nó sẽ chỉ ra là tám thôi
nhưng mình cái đấy được ra tôi nghĩa
cũng không Anh Hoàng lắm đâu
Ừ đúng rồi Xuka là cái con mua xô của
la.lon có sẵn có thể là xe ha date Nhưng
mà mình mình đang hướng dẫn các bạn là
theo hướng là cài đặt lại hết từ đầu
và đương nhiên là cái có sẵn rồi tiện
hơn không ạ
Ừ nếu không có thể kiểu vào computer ở
chạy xe bắt bếp cũng được như bạn kia có
nói đúng không Tôi quên lại đây
và tiếp theo đó là nếu trong trường hợp
mà
giống như một bạn hôm trước của tôi bị
dính khi mà kéo cốt Ví dụ ở mấy ông đẩy
cốt này lên đúng không là sử mấy ông tôi
tôi đầy cốt lên cái Zippo của tôi ở
chẳng hạn đúng không xong với ông kéo
cốt của tôi về cho mày Ông thử chạy thì
không chạy được bởi vì sao Bởi vì khi mà
đẩy cốt lên đấy có một đặc điểm ở đây
mấy ông ý nhé
Ừ thôi mở code lên cho bánh xe này
Ê thằng này nó bị
Ừ đợi thì đừng bao giờ chia sẻ quyền này
nữa
Ê mày bé ông à Cái giao diện tôi bị làm
sao ý
a mã giao diện tôi cái này phải trông
khác mày giao diện Tôi không
chắc mặc định nghỉ rồi nha bạn đã trưởng
Bạn tạo link mít cho anh nhé
A Gọi giao diện phải như thế này chứ
à à
ờ ờ
ừ ừ
Ừ cái cái vụ nếu mà nếu mà Mấy ông kéo
cố của tôi vậy từ Xipo về mày ông sẽ
không chạy được về sao bởi vì tôi không
hề đẩy cái
file.nc này lên mấy ông thấy nó sẽ là
màu màu da cam và này nó không được đẩy
lên nó bỏ qua này giống thư mục men đo
này em thế nghĩa là mấy ông mấy ông để
ông ấy Ông muốn đấy là mấy ông sẽ phải
copy cái file nv này file nv trở
miscible đấy ông sẽ tạo lại thành cái
file.nc như thế này đấy ông ạ thì ra nó
khá giống nhau mà họ rất giống nhau
chẳng có gì cả nó chỉ khác một cái duy
nhất nó để ông Để ý kỹ nó có cái Active
và không có app quy ở đây đây Thế thì
hôm nay và thường với ông Nếu mà mày ông
có thắc mắc gì thì mày không có cha thôi
như thế này thì nó sẽ đề xuất cái kiểu
như này à
thì nó sẽ đề xuất là mày không cần phải
làm gì sao
em bỏ qua mấy cái này mấy cái chuyện này
của Vertu nhé Cái này đã là tạm một cái
file nv sau đó thì chạy cái này Đấy con
nếu mà không được nữa thì có thể chạy
thêm hai cái này để xóa cách xóa mấy cái
thứ thứ đi lại kiểu như thế
à à ý nghĩa là mấy ông có thể copy copy
cài wifi V cho máy xe bồn này đã
xe đạp thành file thành một cái phải nv
sau đó ghi chạy chạy cái này để nó tạo
ra một cái ascii một cái sứ kia cho cá
của mấy ông còn tác dụng của nó gì rồi
không nhớ lắm đó không nhiều cái tác
dụng của cây ap tác dụng gì đấy khá là
mày phải có cái đấy thì mấy ông và mấy
ông và kéo Cốt về Thế mày ông không ngồi
thư mục máy đo Tới giờ vẫn chưa có cốc
gì cả chỉ có mình cái cốc cơ bản này chứ
chưa có thư viện gì cả thì mới ông sẽ
phải chạy compose update ạ Còn bây giờ
fb hoặc có rô install install cũng được
thường mà mình sẽ update để nó cập nhật
thêm Pocket thì gió thoại tôi được nhiều
hôm ấy ông chỉ muốn cái thôi Thế này thì
nó sẽ là nó sẽ tải toàn bộ những cái mà
cần phải cài với thư viện về và nó sẽ
tải tiện về đô về lúc đấy Ông đợi nó tải
xong hết kiểu nào như thế này thì mới
ông có thể vào trại cốt được như bình
thường còn không thì Ừ không thì nó sẽ
báo lỗi thì thôi chị ạ
ca nhạc costs with mi của mình thực ra
chưa Rồi bị giới hạn nỗi lên đến 50 Rõ
ràng cái này nó
nó giới hạn 50 nghiệm thứ 2 trở của ông
chưa có buổi nào lên gỡ 50 ông cùng xem
Ngon
Ờ Bây giờ thì mình sẽ mình sẽ dạy các
bạn là làm Shield từ đầu đúng không Từ
webzen
khi bé không còn web cơ bản nữa
xe tải mấy ông thầy có cái đi bắt ba này
em thấy hay không bấm thử cho mày không
xem này nó đăng có cái ví dụ nó nhìn chị
ra đây chưa câu Perry gì này rất là tiện
để với ông tí tiện theo dõi được là đang
tiến trình đang đến đâu muốn bao nhiêu
đây đã sử dụng sử dụng gì mà ghê đấy
không biết luôn
bình Mây không yêu cái gì ở đây Ờ
A và đợi tí được đi nha thật bớt mấy cái
đi
ạ Và bây giờ tôi sẽ tạm Xóa hết toàn bộ
có hôm trước đi và về mình sẽ làm lại
hết đi mình lại làm lại hết
khi nào lại hết từ đâu
Ờ thì đầu tiên thì để để để làm sale thì
đương nhiên làm chúng ta phải có bảng và
tàu bay Có giờ Thư không ạ sẽ vào Doctor
bai máy ông xem lại nhé
thứ hai nhà máy này tôi không cài cái
này
Và như thế Tôi sẽ chạy trai cái này vậy
a new một cái này à
à à
Em chưa có một cái gì cả em mình có thể
là biết à
a-data bay à
So Sorry to school I này
đi
sói Tôi sửa lại cái này Tí
xếp này Oppa này
Ừ nó để thằng này chị cái nồi đền đó tao
bay uschool thôi hiện tại đang chưa có
gì cả Không ạ thi ở đấy khi mấy ông sẽ
nghĩ rằng là lại giống như là home
Không tôi chưa dậy một cái phim Quốc gia
Swift nào đó
tôi sẽ không dại giống như hồi trước là
tôi sẽ tạo bảng bằng câu axwell như này
nữa không Chúng ta sẽ không làm thế mà
hôm nay chúng ta sẽ học thêm một cái nữa
đó chính là mai Vision và tất cả mình sẽ
dùng cốt để tạo ra đấy sẽ ăn đây mới ông
xem nha thì mình sẽ có micro xin
thì mình sẽ dùng cốt để tao bảo thứ nhất
là tại sao phải dùng cốt để mà tạo ra
bởi vì nếu là giả sử mà tôi tạo database
bằng câu f-care ở đây nghĩa là chạy được
trên máy của tôi không ạ sau đó thì thì
tôi lại ý sport cái tao đây Đầy ra để
gửi cho người khác không Nếu mà đã quay
quá nhiều thì chúng ta không được làm từ
đấy mà chúng ta sẽ làm và ta sẽ không
tường minh được để biết được là là bạn
đấy tạo ra như thế nào Có bao nhiêu cột
hãy vân vân mình sẽ và về sau mình sửa
xóa cột các thứ mọi thứ diễn biến như
thế nào được không
Ừ đúng hôm nay mình sẽ up luôn kể cái
quần nữa là Mai ra sân thi thì mình sẽ
phải tạo vào tôi bằng cốt đương nhiên là
nó có hỗ trợ này mình cũng không cần
phải ghi lại câu Apple làm gì cả tôi nói
chúng ta sẽ không cần thì cậu Apple mà
mình sẽ dùng cái mình sẽ dùng những cái
hàm của thằng level hỗ trợ để mình sẽ
tạo tại bà có thừa thứ
thì ở đây
Ừ nó mà các bạn hãy dùng cái lệnh này để
tạo ra file Michael Jackson nhưng
Ừ nhưng mà tôi sẽ không dùng cái này Tại
sao tôi sẽ muốn cho các bạn làm quen
luôn dùng ngay cái thằng cái to là đi
Cái này là các bạn khi ở các bạn tạo đây
để tôi nói nhá Khi mà các ví dụ hồi chưa
có thằng sinh viên ở Ngạn Thì hôm trước
và mình có học đó là là mình sẽ tạo một
cái sinh viên container Đông ạ này tôi
mở cái đó cho tôi sẽ mở cho con mấy ông
ấy Notepad đi
Ok nó phát cộng này
ở
đây bình thường mình sẽ có sinh viên cho
nơi ở ạ
Không ạ à Bây giờ thì tiếng Anh thôi Ok
đừng có cái gì sau đó đi tu dien Model
đúng không nằm trong thư mục Model đúng
không mua đồ này sau đó thì có
mình bạn sẽ là mình vợ sẽ tạo bảng Tư
lần nữa từ đến thấy bồ đúng không
xe tải mình sẽ có bạn thấy bồ này và ở
đây sẽ có là một thằng mua đồ cảm như
thế này đúng
a bít nhất ở người này Hôm trước mình ở
mình đã phải quen việc đào tạo như thế
này đông ạ thậm chí ở mình sẽ còn router
cái gì đó nữa những cái đấy bỏ quá thì
thằng palio nó không chỉ có mỗi thế
không chỉ có mỗi thế nó sẽ tạo những cái
gì nữa nó sẽ có tạo cái khái niệm là
Factory này sheet này sau đó thì ôi
ccproxy cho tôi không nắm rõ lắm và có
nhiều cái nữa giống như ông thấy ở đây
đây nó sẽ có khi mà dùng cái lạnh ô của
nó sẽ tạo hết cả từ modal migration như
này hết toàn bộ tất cả đúng này nó là gì
modal thì mày không biết rồi Mai xin
chính là cái em thử thôi Sắp Nói đây đó
tạo bảng dùng cốt để tạo ra bạc đấy tiếp
theo cái Factory và Shiper Tức là cái dữ
liệu ảo để mà Mấy ông sẽ tự động in xơ
và chẳng mấy bạn đây ví dụ là sự Bây giờ
là mấy ông thay Nhưng nếu nhập tay để mà
Insert vào trong cái bàn đấy Không chúng
ta không làm thế chúng ta sẽ cho chúng
ta một test đến hàng nghìn hai hả triệu
bản ghi cùng một lúc đúng ạ chủ chúng ta
muốn chạy tại trại cốt để mà sinh ra
ngẫu nhiên hàng triệu triệu người dùng
để mình test các thử thứ thì sẽ dùng cốt
để mà làm được đấy ông ạ
oxy như tội nói tôi chưa biết cái này
lắm rồi tìm hiểu sau cái controller thì
các bạn nắm rõ rồi và cuối cùng là cái
request này Harry quét nước là cái vai
they để kiểm tra dữ liệu nhập vào đâu ạ
thì trong này nó khái niệm nó đọc gọi
quét
Vì thế nên là Tức là bây giờ mày không
sẽ hiểu là để mà thường là khi mà Khởi
tạm một cái gì đó là tôi sẽ chạy đúng
mỗi lệnh này ông như thế này Đấy đầu
nhọn tôi sẽ copy cái này đương nhiên là
bây giờ thì đổi cái này chữ Sinh viên Tư
Đơn đúng không Dịch tiếng Anh từ lên tôi
chạy các lệnh này tới cả tôi sẽ tạo khởi
tạo mua đồ và kèm theo toàn bộ những cái
gì có thể Dạo này cứ chạy
có ai nó sẽ tạo ra cho tôi như này đây
vào trong cốc thì nó sẽ tạo ra rất nhiều
cái tôi xem cho mấy ông xem a thường mà
tôi sẽ
a cho mấy ông xe mà
Ừ cái này để biết qua được hả Lại có
nhiều cái bị xóa bỏ qua nhé này nó tạo
thêm xinh mik request này mày đưa quét
này tôi chưa dậy vội mấy ông cứ bỏ qua
đã
ở trạm xá
ô tô tại về đây ăn tạm được đấy con con
ngựa chưa động vào mình sẽ có thằng
model này mình sẽ có thằng cần cho l này
như này nhở đấy
Ê thằng này đang ốp cái có sẵn rồi
anh đợi tôi một tí nhé Tôi không thích
chỗ có sẵn ngay đi
mọi người thấy Hay đợi tôi tí thôi xóa
sư hết đó ngoài đi vậy
Ừ Thôi trả lại đi
xe máy
a disk app nó lại đi
Và như thế Tôi không chạy ô đã ô nó bị
nhiều quá đợi thì sẽ chạy lạ nha
cơ cấu tạo những thứ tôi cần tạo thôi
mua đồ
I my Vision Tôi sẽ chỉ tạo myosin à
khi mở không đã
à à
Ừ ừ thế Có khi copy đoạn bên này tạo mới
cái chuẩn đi
khi
cài quy tắc để mà tạo Mike Tyson cái đặt
tên của cái file micro này thì khi mà
tạo bảng nếu không sẽ Chris sau đó thì
gia đình thêm chữ s này thấy bồ nha
không ạ Không có chữ S đằng sau thấy bố
đâu nó sẽ hiểu ngay tạo được cái file
Magiê xin ba cái file này sẽ được tạo ở
trong cái thư mục này mình sẽ có 1 thư
mục tạm tắt tôi phạt tắt hết ra ngoài
này nhá Tôi mở lên nhé Nếu sẽ nó đã ta
Bây này mai xin này sẽ có pha này để tạo
những cái file này là những file được
tạo sẵn của nó rồi và mấy ông Thực ra bé
uống thể tham khảo qua cốc thôi Chứ
thường rồi tôi sẽ không dùng những cái
cốt có sẵn này của nó lại xóa đi
em hãy tự xóa đi Tại sao lại nên xóa đi
về vịt Nếu mà tí mình chạy có lệnh
migration là để mà dùng cốt để mà tạo ra
bảng ấy thì nó sẽ tạo luôn cả những cái
bạn đấy thứ mà tôi không cần
Ừ thì ông thấy là khi mà chạy cái này
lập nước vào nó sẽ có viết có sẵn cho
mấy ông đó là à nó sẽ nó sẽ có mặc định
cả ID ID là tức là gì IDE tức à cột tự
động tăng mà cột đấy kiểu BIG tin tức là
kiểu dạng là là kiểu số số kiểu y đi nha
cái mic rất là lớn và thêm một cột và
hai cột nữa Ở đây tham Style theo chữ s
được là nó xuống đúng không em 2 phút
nữa Tức là Crystal chất và av-test thực
ra là tại sao lại có thêm 2 cột này Tại
sao lại có thêm cột D that best of that
là khi mặc mì ông Insert vào bản ghi mới
nó sẽ tự động Điền ở trong cột này làm
chị là ông vừa mới đăng ví dụ cái phù
hợp cho việc là Ông vừa đăng ký thêm
sinh viên mới
hai thí sinh viên đề về sau thống kê sao
mà số lượng sinh viên nhập học và 20 22
hay gì đó thì sẽ bao nhiêu sinh viên thì
sẽ dựa theo cột này còn cột ấy tấn tức
là được cập nhật lần cuối
Ý là lúc nào Cột này thì nó phù hợp cho
việc à để mà ông dễ tra soát xe mà là
là kiểu được thay đổi lần cuối là lúc
nào có sự hư thì kê bảng sinh viên thì
tôi nghĩ là không không không cần cột
này cột này thì mèo có thể tùy mày không
thể vẫn để ở đây chỉ cách để mấy ông vẫn
để được nhà mấy ông thơ ca chỉ cần có
cái này viết lại cũng được như thế này
xe bọc ai đi được
ý
là như này
đấy thế cũng được
Ừ nhưng mà tôi nghĩ là cách đơn giản
nhất thì tôi tạm chưa dậy người ông về
mấy cái đấy Tạm tạm chưa dậy nhé
thì nó sẽ dạy cho mấy ông từ cay dễ
trước đã tôi sẽ dạy cơ bản
Nếu làm quen trước đã rồi tôi sẽ dậy mấy
ông nâng cao nâng cao dần sau không
không xa về sau muốn thêm thì vẫn thêm
được không sao ờ Ok ở đây
ở đây mình sẽ có bằng sinh viên này
[âm nhạc]
mình sẽ có thêm những cột vì mình sẽ có
thấy bồ đây này
A và mình sẽ là kiểu sinh Nêu như thế
này
thí sinh này tức là gì chuyện này sẽ
hiểu là và tra đấy nó sẽ là cá tra và nó
sẽ nếu mà mặc định như này nó sẽ hiểu là
200 ngăn mấy ông có thể là đổi nó thành
5 mưa nhé em ạ Để em chế độ dài nói
chuyện 50 ký tự thôi đấy tiếp theo là gì
nhỉ mã lớp đúng không Nhưng mà thôi Tôi
tôi tôi chưa dậy mấy ông sang hai bạn
vội Tôi sẽ dậy mấy ông cứ một bạc các
thứ trước đã anh sẽ có nêm này còn gì
nhỉ ờ
à à
em giả sử là mình sẽ có
thì mình sẽ cậu date này 3 kiểu bớt đây
đi nhà đi là kiểu
mất nết đi mất nết giờ ngày sinh này còn
gì nha à
Và như thế Tôi sẽ để đẹp first name Nha
và một cái last name
Anh hiểu một cái là họ làm cái tên đi
thời trang áo tôi sẽ đúng rồi còn à Giới
Tí nữa tính buồn lần đúng không
anh không không nên để không để Đây là
sách đó nha
poland à
Ừ Rồi tạm thời điểm này
gì để mà chạy được cái này thì mới ông
sẽ có cái là petition này
về Minecraft
ở đâu ạ đó sẽ chẳng ai
thì nó sẽ báo lỗi ở đây Tại sao lỗi này
Nói chung là tôi làm sẽ có một loạt mỗi
để tôi sẽ giải thích lần lượt cho mấy
ông không ạ Cái Cái lỗi này liên quan
việc nó bảo không tìm thấy tao đây này
đúng rồi tại sao một vì mấy ông Ấn lại
file nv này nếu không sẽ thấy ra mặc
định mặc định của nó ba tơ bay sẽ tên là
razzil mà tên là tao bậc của mình vừa
rồi là j School không ạ sẽ đổi này
schools này thì các bạn sẽ biết được cái
file nv này bạn chất nó là để mà con Fix
là cấu cấu hình mà cấu hình này chỉ cấu
hình theo dạng là một lần dụng dùng được
thoải mái
Vì sao mày tôi đâu rồi Nhớ cái face tôm
với thỉnh thoảng nó bị đơ rồi Nhiều ông
bà chứ tôi quá ơi
e
meo meo thì babystore Tử Đơn
Ô hay nhỉ
À có nghĩa do cái cốc Women là nặng quá
Cho tôi xin phép tôi tắt máy đi mà lại
vậy
cho babystar chết rồi à
anh
nói chung là cái phải Neo V kia là file
config tất cả mấy ông sẽ chỉnh trong cái
file nv đấy để mà cấu hình kết nối cơ sở
liệu hay cấu hình về sau cấu hình tài
khoản các từ thứ sẽ nằm trong phải là
ghê đấy
Ừ tối tạo lại Linh nhé nếu vào lại nhé
Em biết sao bị lỗi thế
xe
tải thì tôi sẽ vào phải em phải nv này
tôi sẽ đổi nó thành zooskool không ạ
anh nghe này đó Bây giờ tôi chạy thử lại
phát nữa này
ở đó
vẫn có phải được tao hỏi nha phải nằm ở
đâu rồi à à
chờ đợi gì ai nằm ở đâu nhỉ À bộ phim võ
túc xá file này rồi mày nghỉ à
- có nhỉ điêu thế
nó
đánh rõ ràng File này bị xóa rồi mà
Ừ thôi kệ đi Kệ đi à
xe tải lại này có phải
group đi
anh ạ
Ừ thế thì ông sẽ thấy là có hai cái bảng
đấy sẽ được tặng 1 bảng bảng malaysian
để mà nó sẽ lưu lại và những cái gì Cái
fire được được chạy rồi Để mình sẽ không
chạy lại phát nữa sẽ không trường hợp là
về sau chạy Mai xin nó lại tạo nên phát
nữa là cái thứ hai
người thứ hai đó là bảng của mình để tạo
đây em sẽ thấy là nó nó sẽ là kiểu tự
động tăng áo túi kleeman đấy và ăn xa
không âm luôn này và biết y là tự động
và số giờ to để mình lưu lại nói chung
là chục tỷ được đấy tiếp theo là và tra
lại bếp này tất cả những cái này mặc
định sẽ là không được phép Mun Còn nếu
mày ông muốn cho nó nun thì mới ông sẽ
phải thêm luôn enabled ấy nữa như thế
này à
khi Ronaldo này thì nó sẽ hiểu được em
luôn thi mấy ông xem cái đấy thì mới ông
sẽ xem qua cái tài liệu này nhá vẫn là
trang chủ nào leo mà không đập dụ ở đây
tôi cho mình xem qua nhé lại thường là
sẽ Tao tưởng ngay Trinh xong rồi
timestamp Như này không ạ lại có thứ
à Xong rồi đây nó sẽ có những cái hàm
nữa mà thường mặc định ở ông chỉ còn
chạy hàng này thôi nhưng có những thêm
hàm nữa là robot này quay lại này quay
lại bao nhiêu bước này vân vân ra một
cái đấy Ông ấy ông ý dùng á mày ông có
thể có một trong những cái mày không có
thể sẽ dùng giống như chung dùng đó là
reflect là sẽ chạy lại từ đầu này
anh bay nó sẽ robot và chạy lại này thì
cái này nó sẽ cá rô bát Tức là nó sẽ
quay lại và chạy lại nó sẽ cơ chế như
nào nó sẽ chạy vào cái bao rồi này cái
đao này nó sẽ phải ngược lại với cái
trên này là sử cái chuyện này tạo thì
cái này sẽ ra giúp này vân vân vân và
cái và cái này Thực ra tôi không khuyến
khích mấy ông chạy fast fast lắm vì nó
sẽ có thể giúp lại cả toàn bộ các Thủy
Hử thì nó không tốt lắm
anh nói chung cái này mày ông về xong
rồi Ông tìm hiểu mình sẽ hiểu
ở đài tiếp theo là tạo bảng đây nếu
không thấy ra nó còn thêm những cái kiểm
tra xem lại bảng này có tồn tại không
hay là có cột tồn tại không vân vân
anh nói chung học đây tài liệu của nó
nên nó sẽ rất đầy đủ đầy đủ Nhưng thực
tế là tôi nghĩ là mấy ông cũng không
Không nhất thiết phải
anh biết hết được tất cả những cái này
mà Mấy ông sẽ chỉ cần xem qua những gần
nhiều khối đấy tôi xem à tớ sẽ lướt
nhanh đừng đoạn Xem À nó hỗ trợ những
cái kiểu dữ liệu là kiểu gì sẽ bấm vào
chẳnghạn giống như kiểu mấy cái kiểu như
thế này
kiểu boolean hai cha gì đó như này thế
là được đấy Ở đấy có rất nhiều nói chung
và mấy ông sẽ hiểu được làm chủ Để con
có lệnh và buổi hôm sau tôi sẽ dạy với
ông việc là tạo cải tạo cả khóa ngoại để
mà ràng buộc nữa
Ê
mấy ông muốn unique thì ông sẽ kiểu gạch
ngang rồi uống nick nhá là sử trong
trường hợp này mày ông muốn để unique
này sẽ kiểu muốn đi qua đúng không như
thế này thì sẽ là tên bắt buộc nó phải
duy nhất không ạ
Ừ ok
Bây giờ nói chung và mình tạo xong cái
bảng rồi đúng ạ thì mình sẽ làm gì tiếp
bây giờ mình sẽ cần là làm đầy đủ tính
năng xem thêm sửa xóa thôi Không biết
hôm nay có kịp không cơ cứ làm được cái
đâu làm nghé ọ
thì mình sẽ quay lại bên mình sẽ có khái
niệm erawan ở đây nhá với ông bé ông sẽ
ở lại quân Ghét chính xác từ đây này Đấy
mình sẽ khởi tạo một cái l quần à Một
cái mô đồ nhưng tại sao nó gọi quần thì
để cách tên của Lara đặt cho cái thằng
mà mua đồ nói quần bởi nó kế thừa cái
quần thế thôi
Ở đây bây giờ tôi sẽ chạy này
cứ đình không có thêm ít nhé thường thôi
chứ không phải cái ID là tự rửa của m ci
mà là ID thì nó sẽ cài ID nè Còn bản
chất nó là là cột tự động tăng và mặc
định Cô tự động tăng ở trong máy ép keo
nó cho sạm da khóa chính rồi đấy giản
thì thôi
à nếu nếu mà em chạy mấy câu lệnh SQL
nhiều lúc nó sẽ báo lỗi ở ví dụ ra chậm
cột này bận à chỉ được có một cột tự
động ta mà cột để bắt buộc phải đi
ở
đây cái ID là viết tắt của cái đoạn đấy
để mình ngắm ngắn gọn hơn thôi
Ê hồi hồi hồi trước nó không tiện được
nhà hồi trước phải bắt buộc đi rõ đầy đủ
ra cho khai báo với kia có sự lăng nhăng
phết bây giờ càng ngày là cam tiện hơn
rồi
Ờ Ờ
nói chung là tạo mua đồ cho nghỉ ok tạo
rồi đúng không tạm mua đồ thì mấy ông có
thể vào bên xem nên xem ấn áp này mua đồ
này có tên này tạm Xóa Thằng user đi nhá
người ông mình không dùng rồi đâu đấy
Thật sự đơn này thì mặc định thì ông sẽ
thấy là nó có sử dụng hát
Factory như tôi sẽ tạm giữ nguyên đây
tôi chưa động với nó dao động với nó vội
ạ Bây giờ Bây giờ ở đây có một cái hay
đó nhá đó là chỉ cần như này thôi nó lắm
mặc định mặc định lấy cho ông kệ nối
được bền cho cái bảng là tư đừng hiện
chữ f rồi nếu là giật sự là bạn của ông
không có có phải xưa dần thêm F2 bảng
của ông tên là sinh viên này ạ Ông thích
để tên bảng lại tiếng Việt các ạ thì mới
ông sẽ phải ở đây là public ông sẽ phải
khai báo kiểu nha gà tra trên tình chính
tài liệu của nó sẽ có ai ông sẽ phải
iPhone thích thật chứ không phải vâng
Đây này nó sẽ ở nhà nó sẽ muốn sửa lại
tên bạn không phải sự đền thêm ít mặc
định nó sẽ hiểu là tên của bộ mua đồ rồi
thì chết đấy thì mày ông sẽ phải trở lại
do nó ra sửa sinh viên chẳng hạn như này
được không ạ Còn nếu là mấy ông mà tên
nó kiểu thống nhất theo cỡ ngày rồi thì
mấy ông không cần nói thêm rồi đó
Ừ ok chưa đó
sau đó Thì bây giờ mình sẽ làm gì
Đi chùa mà tôi sẽ tạo thêm cả controller
nữa có thể viên câu lệnh nha hoặc cả tôi
sẽ thận kiểu thủ công đi thôi tôi tạm
chưa biết có lệnh Tại sao rồi Tôi muốn
nhá dậy cho mấy ông controller từng bước
từng bước một con nếu mà chạy câu lệnh
như tạo cân cho l mấy ông nhìn cái mông
sẽ bị hoa bởi vì nó hiển thị ra hết tất
cả các hàm rồi
tôi sẽ tạo một cái file trai ở
controller đi
xe container từ định container đúng
không không không thêm em nhé
PB này à
chợ đêm phải giờ trai luôn Tôi sẽ copy ở
bên này
Ê bà tôi sẽ xóa những cái này đi
Ừ
từ đền controller à à
à à
ừ ừ
Anh
thường ấy thường là nó sẽ kế chùa một
thằng controller nữa nó sẽ cái thừa
Chính thằng container này nhưng tôi sẽ
để vẫn giữ nguyên bản Thuận ở đây nhé Ok
tôi sẽ có một cái hàm
cho tôi tôi sẽ muốn ở đây tôi sẽ hiểu
lại như sau ở bên mình quay lại bên dâu
tôi đi
ở quầy biến quét router các thứ thứ
Ê mày không nhớ là hôm trước khi nào vào
trang web của mình ở nghìn chị ra cái
phom trưởng ai không ạ nhưng bây giờ khi
mới vào trang web của mình tôi muốn hiển
thị ra đây Tôi muốn nghĩ cái gì Tôi muốn
mình chị ra luôn mà toàn bộ sinh viên
chẳng ạ là sử tôi những cái nhập trai
rồi ra ngoài sẽ có một bạn sinh viên
trước đi thật sự đấy à
anh Long này Nguyễn này
và đây sẽ là
Anh sinh năm 1997 này cách tạo này được
ờ ờ ờ
một đi Nó kiểu ngay mua bạn sinh viên cả
ngày không ạ thì tôi muốn là khi mới vào
thì sẽ hiển thị ra bạn sinh viên đấy báo
không tồn tại đây bây giờ trong trường
hợp này đưa mình sẽ phải sửa lại
Anh thường là thường là mấy ông đây cái
cách tôi vừa làm mình không xem kỹ lại
nhé Khi mà yêu một cái gì đó đây mình sẽ
luôn chọn cái illuminati xong rồi cũng
cách treo sport kiểu ngay xong rồi pha
két như này chọn này sau đó thì ấn An
enter để mà chọn xanh kiểu nó yêu kiểu
nhà cho nó cho nó gọn này cái này là tôi
vừa nói là các phím tắt của bên trên tôm
nhé còn phòng nào
khi mẹ bé có thì tôi không biết không
tiếp theo là tứ Đình
Cẩn cho lô này
nó
như này đó nó sẽ tự động yêu cho mình và
lúc đầu tôi sẽ có một cái Hà mà hàm
index như này đó Bây giờ tiếp theo mình
sẽ có 3 pic xong chưa Làm một cái hàm
tưởng Index nha à
về bản chất ở đây mình cần lấy là gì
mình cần lấy toàn bộ từ đừng về bằng
toudan
anh nghe này
ạ sau đó thì mình sẽ gọi đến hàng là hàm
ô đến đấy tất cả ngày à
em sẽ hiểu lấy hết tất cả về đấy ông ạ
sau đó thì mình sẽ cần Return về một cái
view Tôi sẽ đặt tên thư mục
là tư đinh
300 idex trưởng ngày
nó không phải cái chéo mà nó chấm tức bà
nó sẽ hiểu được là mình sẽ có thư mục và
sư đình và trong cái thư mục đấy sẽ có
file lại ếch đúng ạ Hãy cách viết của nó
sẽ khá là khác sau ở khối mình là pê
nhìn trong mình mình thấy nhìn trong nó
đỡ hơn Tại mình sẽ có
đi chuộc này sẽ tạo ra một cái thư mục
là tư gần thêm chữ s này
331 file mà file index
A và lần này mình sẽ dùng Blade để bể
các bạn biết qua luôn về Blade không ạ
Ừ nó
chị đã đầu tiên mình sẽ có thể hắn một
đây à Đây là danh sách sinh viên à nữa
anh về việc
với tòa lại cha mày
I
went to us nó không mà bảo không tìm lại
cái view nhé đó đúng không Thì ông sẽ
bấm lại vào đây để xem này kéo cái tên
này đúng sẽ thấy tôi đang sử dụng cày
view này cũng có một câu truy vấn ở đây
là sẽ lấy Phong Tử đình nó sẽ tự động
lấy hộ ông qua gọi đến cái hàm này nó sẽ
hiểu là chạy câu truy vấn select sao để
ông ạ ạ ạ
Ừ thì ở đây mình cần mình cần truyền cái
student xanh mình sẽ đây là
ở tại slight student I à à
I got talent
Em làm sự truyền thẳng sư đèn xanh
Anh Vũ Hải Sơn không biết anh ạ
sau đó thì mình sẽ có ở đây là biết tôi
nghĩ là tôi sẽ cài một cái thư viện là
cái Block in Blade nghĩa là tôi tôi nhớ
là có
đợi nhé
em không nhớ cài trên máy rồi đó chưa
chưa chưa Có
jack plat này
Ừ tao idea ở không có Blade rồi
khi con muỗi màu này
Nghe ca nhạc
A Gọi chai vậy thôi không sao gọi chạy
thấy bồ đúng không
tr th thì sẽ có ai đi này ai đi thường
thường bên Tây ID viết tắt sẽ dùng cái
dùng cái này chứ không phải ghi hàng cho
AE nhé
khi nêm này
tôi sẽ lại ế và Window nha đấy sẽ port
này
này sẽ có là đô la xứ đình
a a student
hai
iPhone X này
an
toàn nhà mình sẽ ktr TD
anh ở đây sẽ tự đinh
ở trọ đến ID
âm nhạc tôi chạy thử mày không xem trước
nhé Ở đây sẽ có là bò đơ
ở vòng 1
with là một trăm phần trăm
ở
đó ông sẽ thấy à à
anh nghe nung bãi là dịch
Mio mấy ông sẽ thấy là cái cái này của
tôi nó đã được biến thành đối tượng luôn
đúng không Mày không Để ý kỹ ở đây đối
tượng nó mới sẽ bỏ được Thôi cậu như này
chứ không phải là kiểu dạng như hồi
trước mình làm là theo kiểu như này
không ạ kiểu ngày tôi nhớ không lầm như
vẫn chạy lại vẫn chạy nhưng mà chúng ta
sẽ không làm thế chúng ta sẽ làm các đối
tượng sẽ sẽ sẽ kiểu hiệu dùng xấu dấu
mũi tên nghe này cho xanh là mà làm được
ngay thì bản chất cái thằng Riders đã hỗ
trợ cho các bạn từ a đến z tất cả vụ đầy
rồi đó là từ việc là nó sẽ lấy lấy dữ
liệu với ông không phải viết lại câu
truy vấn mà Mấy ông cũng sẽ nó sẽ tự
động biến cho mấy ông thành đối tượng để
em bé ông có thể gọi được như thế này
không ạ ừ ừ
Em thấy chưa Bây giờ giả sử mình sẽ lấy
theo để phết lên này ạ
à à
anh như này
cho sự ra nhưng mà Mấy ông nhớ mới ông
kiểu như hình bé ông sẽ ví dụ ra sự mất
nêm này số mẹo sẽ cắt ra một cái rồi
last name cậu ngay à
à à
Ừ Thì trong nó khá bất tiện khi nào mày
ông cốt cái đoạn này chứ ở trong nó là
cốt nó không hẳn là xấu lắm nhưng mà nó
vẫn bất tiện tý thôi sẽ chỉ mày ông
giống như hồi trước mình từng cũng viết
cái hàm mấy ông nếu béo còn nhớ là mình
đã từng viết hàm để mà để mà kiểu ghét
họ tên nó nhanh đúng không ạ thì tôi sẽ
chỉ em bé không Cái đấy chuyên sâu hơn
của bên Eric Quân
à à
e2f vẫn cả chuyện đâu lại thế đây giả sử
là bây giờ rõ ràng là mấy ông lưu lại ở
trong đã tới bây giờ mày ông nữa bớt
đúng ạ tưởng như thế này như là tôi muốn
lấy tuổi nó ra thì tôi sẽ có thể dùng
hàm để nó lấy tương tự thế với render
trên Đô thì nó sẽ chỉ có một phải không
thôi như ông muốn thị nào ra một lòng
béo ít theo đây với ông sẽ xử lý ở đây
nhưng mà như tôi từng nói ở bên view thì
nên hiển thị ra thôi nó không còn nên xử
lý gì ở đây cả cái xử lý mình sẽ phải xử
lý ở bên bác em xử lý ở bên A bên hàng
đối tượng này à
khi đó ngoại à
Ừ nhưng mà bây giờ tôi chẳng biết rồi
Chị mày ông nên chị luôn không Tôi nghĩ
là kiểu gì tội sẽ dậy mấy ông nè tra
thôi tôi sẽ tôi sẽ dậy thôi Đây thì cách
cách để mà mình mình gọi một cái hàm đây
tôi quay lại đây này nhá về để mà lấy
được ra họ tên rồi ạ thì nó sẽ mấy ông
nhớ về vụ két xét không ạ Mình có thể là
kiểu ghét họ tên người đó ngọn Nếu nhiều
lắm
Ừ thì nó sẽ get ơn về đôla ĐT
khi họ
the first name là trả lại
Vì sao đói nói về Dolls
à à last name chẳng hạn như thế này đúng
dứt
cha mẹ ông nhớ lại không
I Call it in a không có voice không bị
tao được không hãy kêu kiểu nhé
Ừ nếu nhớ dặn em
cho tôi sẽ dùng gọi đến Hàm kiểu như này
như hồi trước mình làm
em thử xem nhé
đó là được đúng không Đấy mình có thể
chơi kiểu cách như thế này
30 bình minh chị nhá Tôi đang chỉ ví dụ
thôi nhưng nhưng mà chúng ta không chơi
Theo Cách Trở ngày tại sao vì các bạn
nhìn thấy ai trông nó hơi khó nhìn so
với rõ ràng mình đang gọi kiểu ngay tự
gọi cho cậu là gạch dưới gạch dưới tự
nhiên ở đây mình sẽ gọi kiểu hàm thằng
nó có cơ chế tiện hơn viết theo kiểu này
rất nhiều nó sẽ được cơ chế nó là cơ chế
của nó đây nó sẽ là ở đây nó sẽ khái
niệm làm mu Tây tổ và và
à à Asanzo đại biểu Hiệp bấm vào đây cái
ra hơi xấu một tí cái này tất là sao cái
này làm mấy ông có thể khởi tạo cái ạ
tibbers Cho nó
ô ồ cái xe nó phải mới hơn đấy Đợi tí
nhé
khi họ tên khác nhau đừng nóng ngon Đợi
mình chị
Ừ nó viết cách viết của thằng này nó
khác hơn cách viết hồi trước của tôi
từng học
Em đừng có hai đội nhiều đây thử copy
cho mấy ông nhé Đây này
đã nghe thời gian béo không cần khai báo
đấy cũng được nghe thôi ta cũng phải yêu
nó rồi tôi yêu nhé
Ừ nếu nhớ luôn nhớ nó có cái bạn in ass
là gì đó này thì mấy ông có thể yêu rồi
nhé đấy
Ừ cái kỹ kệ đi cái này thức ra sao Bây
giờ tôi sẽ lấy là đấy họ họ tên là sử
phun đây mà tôi sẽ đặt tên Ấy full name
đi lấy cả họ có tên như thế này và ở đây
mình sẽ cần ở đây là
không không không bình tĩnh bình tĩnh à
anh bình tĩnh á Cái này có khi không
đúng đâu
The Flu này không đúng đấy
à à You may want a Chipu
Ừ đợi tao tí nhưng không đúng đâu
chú cá heo là Lara đâm Đúng rồi lao 8
thì nó sẽ ra kiểu khác ta leo 9 này có
vẻ hơi khác tôi từng là không sao tôi sẽ
ngồi mò cùng bé ông thôi
à à ở đôla đôla vol hơi lạ nhỉ à
à à
Ừ Ừ hình như là lấy cái abir này được
đúng không để tôi thử nha à
thay đổi bởi vì thường hội cho tôi dùng
doris để mà đấy không dùng kiểu đó đó
chi bi rồi ngay
à à
khi truyền vào này
ừ ừ
thì
mình sẽ đây sẽ là first name này so nối
chuỗi với các em một cái này rồi nối với
Chibi last name này
Anh nói như thế này sau đó tôi sẽ gọi
đình cái full name này bằng cách là tôi
sẽ
một là béo có thể chơi kiểu như ai hay
là mấy ông thể chơi kiểu ngay và ba làm
méo có thể chơi còn cách dưới nghe được
là nhà tôi thử trong xem họ sẽ tự động
nó sự tự động hiểu cho bé ông có em sẽ
không Nếu có thể là viết thế Cậu biết
hoa nhà anh được nó vẫn sẽ nhận nó ngọn
tôi chưa biết viết theo kiểu ngay nó sẽ
báo lỗi không nhớ không đâu
dự
báo lỗi thật anh ở Nghệ An chỉ ở chỉ
biết được một trong hai kiểu ngay
thì nó tiện không nó sẽ Tôi tôi thích
nhất ở điểm nó phải ghi được gạch dưới
rồi nhá Buổi tối thường ghi tên cột nó
gạch rồi mà đó nếu sẽ thấy là cách viết
của thằng này nó sẽ khá là dạo này có
thể khá mới với mấy ông của nó đang viết
theo kiểu tối giản với kiểu móng chân
đây kiểu viết phóng trình nó sẽ trả về
Return về một cái gì đó Ừ
À mà đây đây là lấy ra phun lên này là
sự mình một lấy ra sửa Bây giờ tôi không
lấy ra bớt chết nữa Tôi muốn lấy ra ếch
kiểu như này chẳng hạn thì tôi sẽ báo
đây một cái lại ít như này và bản chất
nó là thì nó sẽ lấy cái IQ là hepl
lấy kể lấy cái A review là bớt đúng
không
Ừ
nhưng ở đây có một cái đó là
ở đó đó là mình cần phải đến được ngày
lấy được 5 hiện tại rồi - Có những thứ
mới lấy giá tuổi đúng không Thì ở đây
tôi thường hay là kết
tên nó chẳng lại lấy ra được tuổi thì đó
khó quốc tế Mỹ Phước ta có những gì
Anh nhìn cô Dạo này dài quá tôi cũng đấy
nó sẽ chọn bạn nào ngắn ngắn rồi ý
new đết tham Zone chị nhỉ cái đấy vẫn
Vẫn dài quá lựa chọn Mình ăn hơn đây tôi
sẽ lấy cái này đó Cái này tôi sẽ
anh nghe bản chất là nó sẽ viết vào
trong cái này này
em đợi đi
thì nó sẽ viết theo dõi phóng sinh đi à
ừ ừ
Uh
cho nó sẽ biết thì cậu dạng ngay
Em hãy cứ báo lỗi static không phải lỗi
đâu nó chỉ ở đang gợi ý thôi kệ đây mình
sẽ có ACB ở đây ACB Birthday rồi à
Ừ cái đít ham này
chi tiết tham này thì thực ra là nó sẽ
đếch than mà là có sẵn của Thắng p như
là mấy ông sẽ chỉ cần cái chéo với hoặc
cả mấy ông sẽ biết liền nghe được nó yêu
thẳng như này cái cái Đắt hay mày của pp
này ông không cần phải điều gì đó ta cả
đi cày đang gợi ý tôi thì viết tắt hơn
khi ta thời thế cậu ngay một dòng đó và
bây giờ tôi lấy được tuổi rồi chỉ vào
bên này sửa đây hết nhưng mà lấy được
tuổi trong mấy ông chạy xem thử nhé
ở đó Thế Song nếu sẽ thấy là xử lý không
phải xử lý bellevue mà mình sẽ xử lý ở
bên này Đây là cái hàm ghét của nó và
cũng là hàm Xét luôn Tí mình có thể xét
được luôn trong này nếu béo lý kỹ ở đây
nó sẽ có ghét mày và có cả set ở trong
này mình sẽ ghét sét nằm trong đúng 1
cái thằng này thôi chứ thằng nhưng mà
thứ chúng ta sẽ không xét vào trong phun
nêm hay là nghếch mà mình sẽ xét và cụ
thể là thằng à
Anh tên cột của mình mà đúng không Mình
sẽ không xét và hai cái này cái này cốt
là mình sẽ kiểu ghét là ra để lấy ra
cũng chị thôi Cái tiếp theo thằng cho
window này
cho anh đâu Con này tôi cũng thích theo
kiểu là tôi khi mà lấy ra thì tôi sẽ
tôi sẽ đặt tên nó là cho ăn đêm đi tôi
không Tôi tôi thường hay không để trùng
với tên cột đâu Tôi sẽ để nó khác nữa
nha à
Ê bà ở đây Tớ sẽ ra
anh sẽ viết 2 cổng Return về
Ừ
nếu mà cái thằng này bằng bằng một cái
này
Ừ thì mình sẽ là mail còn không ở sẽ
female chẳng ạ
xe tải và tôi sẽ gọi cho n nêm ở đây như
này ở khoảng cách dưới được
A chạy
Ê mày ông thấy nó bị ra thành female vì
có vẻ là khi lấy ra nó là chuỗi nên này
ra So sánh điều này với sai một là ông
cho kiểu ngay hai em béo có thể không
phải bao giờ vàng bên chị hai giờ băng
thôi Nhưng mà thường là bây giờ tôi làm
đi cậu chặt chẽ màu luôn cảnh báo đây
này luôn phải chặt chẽ Chúng ta sẽ luôn
kiểm tra theo có cả bao giờ và cho nó
chat đấy thì tôi sẽ phải làm hơi kiểu
như này tí đi
ở nam giới tính thứ 3
cho tôi Tôi không nói vụ là chúng ta nên
ủng hộ về tính cái này không em ạ Chúng
tôi em nói là kiểu làm cơ bản Nếu không
quen việc buôn lần các thử thứ chứ chứ
chúng ta không cần phải kiểu làm một cái
trường hợp đấy Lúc tao làm gì cả Có sẽ
lấy cắp chân thì vì sao rồi hướng dẫn
sau
đấy nhưng mấy ông sẽ thấy vừa rồi mỗi
ngày vi của hiển thị mỗi xe lách Thôi
mất nửa tiếng thôi nhiều tôi rảnh Khanh
kỹ cho mấy ông ấy ông quen được việc là
lấy thông tin ra như này ngoan sẽ truyền
thông tin vào xong hoạt động chị ạ nếu
mà hiển thị ra thông tin được kiểu khác
thì sẽ làm như thế nào không ạ
Ừ thì Nhưng mà thường là tôi khuyên sinh
viên ở chúng ta sẽ không dùng hàng ông a
tủa ô chiều lấy tất nhưng mà rõ ra ở
chúng ta thường dùng hàm ghét như này
Tại sao nó bản chất nó như nhau bản chất
nó như nhau
chỉ cho mấy ông chạy bản chất là như
nhau kệ nó cảnh báo đây cái cảnh báo đây
chẳng qua thằng yêu nó không nhận diện
được thằng này thôi ra thằng này có tồn
tại nhé Còn nếu mà để ra việc ông khó
chịu khó chịu với kiểu nhìn như thế này
và và nó không gợi ý là gì cả bởi việc
thường thằng Iran nó sẽ nhìn thấy trò
đây nó sẽ gợi ý cái hàm này có tác dụng
gì và bấm được và mình anh nhưng ai còn
ghét ngay đương nhiên nó không tìm thấy
hàm nó chẳng gợi ý cái gì cả cái cách
thì mấy ông có thể xem được gợi ý mấy
ông sẽ phải ghi thêm quay ở trước ngay à
ạ sau đó thì ghét như này thì sẽ được
Ừ
cái Paris lại tác dụng gì Kali này có sẽ
viết nó thành câu truy vấn và từ đó thì
mình Thiện nhảy được đến những cái hàm
khác thực sự
Ừ nhưng mà Mấy ông vẫn như tôi đã bảo
mày không thức hết có thể viết tắt ngay
Kệ thằng kia nó nó nhận diện đấy
ok à
Ừ cái này vẫn
đi tiếp nhỉ Tôi sẽ trả tôi sẽ dạy mày
ông về Insert ít nhất như thế đúng không
Hãy hôm nay quá phải rồi em có làm chưa
I can't thuốc khẳng định là nó là vẫn
chưa khó lắm Chẳng qua nó mới về khó
nhất ở cái đoạn mà vừa rồi làm cái két
xét này có nhận hơi khó mấy ông có ghi
tôi cũng chưa quen thế này nhìn cái Nếu
là người mới nhìn nhìn bọn này trông cốt
cốt nó viết nó hơi bị khó hiểu quá cái
đoạn này thì ông thể bỏ qua nhá cái đoạn
ghét ra cả Dạo này mày ông không hiểu
mày không thể bỏ qua Vì từ ca thực tế ít
áp dụng lắm thực tế giống như tôi vào
làm trục Ox ơi cô út trên trang chủ về
tới sửa lại chạy được thì được không
được thì nó báo lỗi mà nó không sửa cái
chạy được thì thôi
cho tôi sẽ làm thêm cái thêm nữa rồi
chúng ta sẽ tạm nghỉ để hôm sau lắm sửa
xóa sau Thế hôm nay chị cả không phải
cload mà Chị có sơ đồ thôi không ạ ạ
Mở bài Tôi sẽ có một thẻ ở đây thì đây
sẽ thêm lại nhận đúng không ạ
Ê cái này với mpc có giống nhau không ha
đến giờ ông gọi không nhận ra nó giúp
nhau nó nó bạn Facebook bạn này áp dụng
với xem đây thường là mình sẽ có Hz ở
đây sợi hôm trước và bảo mình sẽ nhảy
lên ngã trên cái gì đó đúng không Nhưng
mà không
cho
ví dụ ở đây là sự tối muốn là tôi muốn
nhá Đó là kiểu ở đây tôi tạo thêm cái
mới này groter mới là tên là đấy sẽ là
kiểu đó hả great thêm đúng không chịu
ngay sẽ gọi đến Hà press chẳnghạn không
thì mới ông sẽ nghĩa Hz ở đây sẽ hiện ra
crit ngay thôi thêm dấu dấu gạch chéo
ngày cũng được đúng không
anh đưa cho mẹ không xem nhé
thì bấm ở đây sẽ gọi đến crash đúng
không
Bây giờ tôi cấu tạo một cái phương trình
là Kris điện nhé à
ông xã mày đi không Đồ nó chấm đây à
à à
thì nó đang trọng nó nhưng mà Tạm thời
tôi lại chưa dậy vội mà tôi sẽ nói qua
về ôm chút về cái vụ này ta mấy ông sẽ
không ở nên để router theo kiểu ngay nó
học cái kiểu như này kiểu đó là kiểu
dạng là cố định cố định và về xong mấy
ông muốn đổi cái router ấy là cái này vợ
female sao
Vì sao này À rồi
xin lỗi cảm ơn ông nhé á
Nghe
có vẻ giới tính là lấy ra là đúng mà số
thật thà đây Ok Ok
em vừa lấy thiếu rồi lấy thiếu u
chỉ tiếc à
ờ ờ
Ừ thế này mấy ông thấy nó đang cố định
và về sau mấy ông muốn thay đổi cái
router này thứ cái ít khi thay đổi âm
nhưng một khi mà ông thay đổi router này
thì toàn bộ những cái đường link cũ nó
sẽ chết ra thấy không tốt nếu là sẽ có
cách khác để là thì em sẽ có khái niệm
là đặt tên nước router đã sửa đây sẽ ra
led nha Chẳng hạn đó sau đó thì mấy ông
chỉ cần khai báo đây như này nó là hàm
rotor nha flash như này nó sẽ kiểu đây à
nó sẽ gọi đến cái router có tên là crack
ta lại sang với ông xem này đường dẫn nó
sẽ kiểu như này nó sẽ Nếu mấy ông Nếu Để
ý kỹ trên Thanh đây tôi sẽ
cách tạo 2 cái cho béo nhìn cho bé ông
dõi nhé
có một cái gạch chéo clip mà một cái à
này thế ma của TB đi không hiểu nha
Xuống dòng của nó này mấy ông Để ý kỹ ở
dưới này của tôi nói đi Chị gì nhé một
cái là web chấm Galio chấm test cá chép
Blade đúng
em cắm cái giấy
ờ ờ hay cãi nhau cứ tưởng cái gì nó khác
cơ chỉ lỗi xin lỗi
nhưng nhưng mà ở đấy Bây giờ sửa là tôi
đổi cái router này chắc chắn hàng này nó
vẫn sẽ giữ nguyên thôi đây tôi sửa đổi
nó thành hằm cái như thế này ạ
chị sẽ có một cái nó sẽ đúng kiểu nó sẽ
theo đúng brother kia và một cái nó sẽ
vẫn sẽ giữ nguyên lỗi tôi lỗi tôi nhớ
cái này hình như nó cứ tưởng là nó sẽ
chỉ gạch chéo biết thôi nhớ về nó vẫn
ghi đầy đủ
nhưng mà cái đoạn router
I mean uống gì tôi không lẽ nếu mà khi
mà không thay đổi ôtô cái này đúng không
Cốt chỗ khác vẫn phải được giữ nguyên
vẫn không phải sửa gì cả Nói chung là
mấy ông phải luôn luôn suy nghĩ và việc
làm về sau mình sửa một cái gì đó thì
cốc chỗ khác nó sẽ ảnh hưởng như nào đấy
lập trình viên có năm kinh nghiệm là
chúng ta sẽ luôn nghĩ điều đấy Đó là
mình sẽ hạn chế sửa ít nhất ít trọng
nhất ở hệ những chỗ nào mà dễ thay đổi
như thế đúng không Thì mình sẽ
Ừ thì mình sẽ phải đặt cho nó một cái
biến em cái giá trị gì đó để mà về sau
mình chỉ cần đổi cái tên biến đổi cái
giá trị của biến đấy đổi cái gì đó toàn
bộ chỗ khác nó cứ nhận đấy nó tác dụng
như thế
khi bé tôi bấm vào đây nó sẽ gọi đến nó
không tôi sẽ ở đây tôi chỉ đơn giản
Return một cái view thôi
I Build ayla
thỉnh thoảng nó cứ bị nhảy nhảy lên trên
với ông ý kiến cũng bị nghỉ trưa cùng
biết do sau gì
cho tôi sẽ tạo một cái file file class
đúng không cái from
class template cho TP
from đây
Ừ thì bây giờ bởi vì nó dùng Blade mình
sẽ có CR lấy nhanh này một cái nút
đây là họ đấy
the first name gì tiếng Anh nha à
thì mình sẽ có thai sex
ở phần mềm Word gợi ý nho này trông thấy
ông gợi ý phải xin Thế à
[âm nhạc]
Ừ
tao nhạc
vào đây à render rồi à
à hay là radio
nêm lại chando ô
chị alo là một cá không
có một cái là mail cho một cài đặt
female rằng ạ
Ở bớt date
phút ạ
à à
[âm nhạc]
I read
ở
lại toàn bộ tiếng Anh nhá hài lòng với
ông chưa Ừ ok
I Pray mình sẽ nhập một cái gì đó đúng
không
anh nguyễn này
ô long trong trường hợp này phé thoải
mái được
thằng lauriel nó sẽ kiểm tra cho mấy ông
để mấy ông sẽ không có bị Wells Jackson
mày không kiên tâm đồng nhập ký tự đặc
biệt một loạt thoải mái được được ạ
Từ ngập một loại khí tự đấy
họ không sao đây Nhập vào này
đi soi Express
à À đúng rồi quên mất tôi sẽ sửa đây nó
sẽ phải nhờ giá chân nó sẽ cũng là
router thôi sẽ nhảy lên protein tên là à
store để lưu lại và Mi Hót của nó mới
thớt thằng này sẽ mấy thớt post
thì ở đây có một cái hay nữa đó là khi
móng khai báo cái gặp router cả nhà chắc
chắn nó sẽ báo cho mình cái lỗi rồi copy
đấy ạ sẽ bảo lỗi là không tìm Naruto như
thế này để bắt buộc Mày khỏe bro đã nóng
mới cho ông tạ ra hai a
ở đội 2 cái này store này à
anh ạ
Ê
thích à
à à
ê ê
vì sao chọn được hai cái công lúc nào ạ
thế nào nhỉ
ờ ờ
và tôi sẽ để đây em mới thớt thường anh
tôi sẽ để mới thớt là boss hiểu tạo mà
đúng không
Ừ nếu không cần phải đổi cái này thành
to nó đâu thường sẽ kiểu kiểu đề kiểu
ngay
có một cả là ghét thì sẽ hiểu bảo nhận
định iPhone compass thẳng vào thì sẽ
hiểu là là lưu ở lại
đợi tí
tôi đã tắt mất cái gì nhé
ở tại bên này
mô tả lại cha mày đưa con này miễn này
các cụm này nó ra ngay thôi Bây inject
nó không tìm thấy Hàn đúng không Vậy
mình đã tạo Hà
bộ phim sex tạo hàm
to nha Trả
tiếp theo là hôm trước mình đã học cách
lấy gái lấy cái từ từ cái form từ đôla
get the support về mình sẽ ở đây mình sẽ
yêu một cài Word cho mình sử dụng nó sẽ
truy quét này
á hậu sẽ góp ý cho thường nó gợi ý hay
nhưng mà gợi ý nó chẳng yêu gì à Tôi sẽ
viết lại tí Ừ nếu nhiều nhé Cái này nói
ra dị nó là dùng cái tôi nhớ không lầm
dùng Cài
Ừ thế nào nhỉ một trong hai cái cho quân
sướng rồi
Ừ hình như là cái dưới nhớ cái giấy
Ừ thế chạy thử sẽ biết từ từ DD cái đê
này một cái giữa 2 nữa của laurel để mà
đi bốc Nó sẽ kết hợp với nó kết hợp đai
bằng là ngăn câu lệnh chạy mừng tại đấy
kết hợp việc và inec in ra giá trị của
mày không luôn tôi thể in nó ra thì tôi
lấy cái á là sự đây cái phốt lên đây ạ
Ê mày bất cứ cái gì lạnh được mà không
cho nó cái này không được thôi chứng tỏ
yêu Price ai ngồi tôi nhớ không lầm mà
yêu cái này thì lại bị dị thế nó phải là
cái like lần này cơ
chứ
không phải
a sport
em ở xa mà
xổ
số bốn đại này mà hình như cái này Đúng
đây
ở đó
Ừ em gọi đúng rồi Cái này Ok Không sao
cứ thử như của Trường hợp tôi không được
thì mình làm lại không say à
ở đây Các bạn thấy thêm một cái nữa cái
tắt mà tôi vừa làm nữa nếu các bạn để ý
đáng lẽ hôm trước rồi tôi sẽ làm ở tôi
sẽ dùng ghét như thế này để lấy ra đúng
không ạ
Ừ nếu nhớ mạ tôi sẽ dùng kẹo ghét nhà
lấy ra nữa nhưng mà bản thân là Eriol nó
thì đọc nhanh và kiểu gõ tắt được Kiểu
ngày nhưng mà tôi thì thực ra tôi thường
anh dùng cái cách kiểu ngày
có nhiều người dạy khó chịu cách này của
vì anh như ông đang thấy đó thằng aiya
nó cứ cảnh báo loạn hết lên đây như này
vào cái hộp việc là có lúc rồi ông sẽ
không lấy được Kiểu ngay nếu không đặt
kiểu tên biến của ông đặt tên với ai chứ
bưu thì ở sẽ không ra được vì ai chiếm
được nó tiếng Anh nó thuộc tính và nó sẽ
hiểu là nó sẽ lấy thuộc tính của hàng
ngày thương mại lấy cái feel tên thuộc
tính như là để ở chắc nhất thì mẹ không
có thể dùng cái này và cái này có điểm
lợi nữa là không chỉ mỗi ghét ngày mới
không có thể lấy được rất nhiều cái kiểu
dữ liệu theo cái kiểu ngay được kiểu dữ
liệu nhé Nếu không thể lấy kiểu ví dụ
một lần thì cái kiểu poland cái thứ mà
tôi sắp lấy cả bốn lần thì mới ông sẽ
được đợi tí anh nói chung 3rd đây ra
không phải đi được rồi đúng không Thì
bây giờ nếu mà giống như hồi trước mình
làm theo kiểu là mpc thì mình sẽ làm
đúng kiểu nghe nhé mình sẽ có sư đền
bằng new student nhân này sau đó sẽ đơn
xét cái gì đó Nhưng Cụ thể lần này mình
sẽ là first name này bằng request ghét
first name này nha chẳng hạn đi last
name này
à à
ý của tôi bị làm sao ấy không không
không sửa nhiều cái cùng lúc được
ở đâu đang ở trọ hay cái lúc ngay chỉ
mất có chịu nghỉ
đúng không
về
đến đâu rồi Bà bớt Tết
à à
ở bên này và mình sẽ chạy Tư Đình xếp
nhà để lưu lại này
A chạy
thì nó sẽ bảo Cái lỗi này nếu mấy Ông
Nếu mấy ông chạy cậu sếp vừa rồi vào lỗi
này là nó bảo không tìm thấy cái cột mày
Tại sao nó làm bảo này mình làm cái cột
này chính vì như thế nó mới vào Cái lỗi
này đó Bởi vì mặc định thằng thằng Model
là sẽ hiểu là cái Ây lô quần này của ông
sẽ luôn có hai cái cột mà vừa nãy tôi
bảo nó cứ thật và em viết thật cái cách
để mà mày ông sẽ không cho hai cuộc đời
tồn tại nhưng mà không sẽ có public
timestamp
thảm tem
bằng phone tối giản chỉ là là mình sẽ
ghi đè lên là không cho hai cuộc đời tồn
tại và tôi chạy thử này còn báo lỗi gì
nữa thì anh sẽ ủng hộ lỗi xin lỗi à Rồi
tên cột này dài quá
cái cái này Thực ra đôi khi vẫn thể ghi
đè được nghe nó nhiều kính báo ông nhiệt
độ dài vậy thì tôi sẽ cho điện nó ngắn
hơn
cảm nhận dài quá
Ừ thôi vừa nãy tôi để nó 50 vậy ấn ấy
thì mới ông sẽ thấy à Vừa rồi rõ là nó
thằng Nam em nó vừa kiểm tra xem chắc
chắn phải in xuất được dữ liệu còn không
ở sẽ báo lỗi đúng ạ chắc chắn ngon niệm
đấy à
a tiếp theo nhỉ tiếp theo thì tôi chỉ
trông Tôi đang định chỉ cho ông mấy ông
tắt hơn được nữa nhưng mà Khởi Nghĩa tắt
qua mấy ông sẽ sẽ choán Nhưng mấy ông có
thể tự nghĩ trước bây giờ giả sử bây giờ
là sử nhé tôi có Tận 20 cái cột ở trong
cái bảng này thì tôi phải điền tập 20
lần lặp đi lặp lại cái đoạn này thì có
nên không và đạp điện là về sau mình sửa
tên cột thì phải làm như nào sửa cột Sửa
tên cột ở ngoài việc mình sữa chóng bom
này mình ở sửa lại lại phải sửa đây là
sửa đó rất nhiều chỗ cần phải sửa nữa
thì ta thế lại càng sai đúng không tí
ông nữa là mình có thêm 10 cột mới thì
mình bạn phải lặp lại thêm mưa Cái này
nữa không đúng không các bạn thử nghĩ
xem ạ hướng giải quyết và cái này nó sẽ
phải như thế nào cho khéo nó tiện nhất
đúng không ạ Bạn ấy câu hỏi cho bé không
để mấy ông cảm thấy là thằng nó đã một
phen word nó phải hỗ trợ tận răng tất cả
những cái vụ đấy để sao cho mình tiện
nhất dễ sửa và cốt nó nhắn cốt có một
lời khuyên này nếu phải luôn nhớ cái quy
tắc của thằng ạ là em nói chung ấy đó là
ra không phải mỗi lao lâu nhớ là là
của mô hình Sony gì vậy đó là ờ
thông
tin control phát model đó
các tin tin hoạt Skinny Skinny được
Skinny Tức là sao nghĩa là ấn chỉ là là
controller nên nên gầy Nếu dịch thu là
gầy ý như ông Chị ở nó nên control nó
lên kiểu ý cốt cho mày thôi Ít có xử lý
do mày thôi controller Ở gần nhau mỗi
xanh mà hồi trước tôi bảo thằng Bùi bàn
nó thằng trung chuyển giữa tất cả những
thằng khác chứ nó không phải thằng xử lý
nếu ông nhớ thằng xử lý hàng nào Thằng
nào thắng chế biến
ở trong cái á
cô gái ông
thằng nào hồi trước là thằng sinh viên
trong nhà hàng hàng chưa biết à
ở đâu vậy thằng mua đồ đúng không Dạ
Đúng giống như trong trường hợp này nó
Phát Nghĩa làm cho béo béo lên đúng
không Nghĩa Chúng ta sẽ xử lý hết ở
trong mô đồ ở những cái gì cần đương
nhiên à Mua đồ thực tế cũng không phải
xử lý hết mà là mô đồ nó sẽ xử lý liên
quan cơ sở liệu thì nó xử lý con những
cái về lôgic nữa thì mình sẽ phải rớt ở
đâu thì về sau mình sẽ tôi sẽ dạy mấy
ông cái đấy cái đấy nó khái niệm nữa nó
khái niệm về ác xin nữa cơ Cái đấy không
phải là nằm trong quy tắc của Lara mà
mình sẽ viết tự về sau mình sẽ vẽ viên
những cái riêng riêng ra để mà xử lý
ở bờ rìa controller về các bạn thì nó
không nên có quá nhiều lâu giết ở trong
này sẽ rất khó đọc đúng rồi xơ mít cũng
được Cũng đúng sờ đít là chân này đợi
lại thế Cậu thấy em trên mình sẽ tách
những cái lôgic nhỏ nhỏ ra những cái
file khác để mà làm còn phải con Zalo
chỉ gọi đến những cây xanh đấy thôi
không nói thằng trung chuyển nó sẽ gọi
đến một loạt những cái thằng nào đó để
xử lý rồi trả về kết quả sống và view có
thứ họ sẽ ngắn nhất có thể đấy
xe Rebel Spirit
oxy Taurus
phát âm từ này ở nhà tôi biết ở đây
Ừ cái đấy nó ra cái đấy không sao nhưng
tôi đọc với nó không phải là quy tắc của
thằng Wow đâu chẳng qua là mình tự tạo
thêm thôi chứ nó cũng không không ép
buộc nó không hẳn là có nó có hỗ trợ
việc có tạo ra nó thì phải nhớ không nói
thế
không phải tự mình viết nhưng lại khá
như thế cây xong lôgic cả mình sẽ xử lý
những phái khác
Ừ chứ không phải giống như rất nhiều
công ty rồi Đi ngay công ty hiện tại tôi
đâu thế
cách trị dứt hết rồi xong câu lâu ra
thấy không tốt 12 con trả lời nó dài quá
thơm nhìn rằng sẽ rất khó đọc và rất khó
để mà về sau kẹo
chỉnh sửa cái gì đó là nó dậy ảnh hưởng
chỗ khác
khi mà rất nhiều cốt mà bị lặp lại nữa
cốt lặp lại giữa hai hiệp về cốt lặp lại
thế mà về sau cùng thay đổi cơ chế ở chỗ
đấy là có nhiều phải sửa rất nhiều số
nữa thế rất là nguy hiểm Đúng không mấy
ông sẽ phải hiểu rằng tất cả những chỗ
đấy phải dùng chung một Hà nạn ở sửa
đúng hàm đấy nó chỗ khác nó vậy chạy thì
nó hợp lý hơn nhờ thực ra có rất nhiều
bài toán có thể xảy ra
anh có thể xảy ra đây nếu mà giờ xử mới
mấy ông giết hết bị bị lười quá cố biết
hết mà trong một ngày hàng thì về sau Tự
nhiên cái cơ chế nó thay đổi nghĩa là
phải chỗ này thì phải làm cái còn lại
chỗ này phải làm được kia thì bé ông lại
phải tách cái Hà mới ra Tại giờ lằng
nhằng
nhà máy ông hiểu nghĩa làm chỉ ở mấy ông
phải tính sao cho mà
Đúng kiểu tin chi đúng kiểu phải biết
được là về sau chỗ này nó vẫn sẽ dùng
chung hai ở dùng riêng nếu mà dùng riêng
thì chắc chắn là mấy ông sẽ phải tách nó
ra Cốt nó thể giống nhau bây giờ về sau
nó thể thay đổi những dễ con nếu mà chỗ
này chắc chắn về sau vẫn phải dùng chung
thì mày không phải Gộp chung lại và
trong một nơi để về sau Dễ chưa ạ
ở buổi ông ông kia cũng nói rất có anh ở
trong công ty rộn ràng đó Violet đã còn
cũng viết vào trong controller đấy là
sai quy tắc rồi chắc chắn à thằng Giang
nó hỗ trợ là có file quét riêng để xử lý
virus nóng lạnh đấy quái dị ở trong
controller đây cũng sai đúng không Đây
có lôgic thì bây giờ cũng phải là ba số
rồi đều rất là controller vì thằng Balan
động Chưa hẳn hỗ trợ ăn tạo hạn ra một
cái file riêng để làm được về bên ngoài
realistic trải qua mấy ông thích thì máy
không thể tặng service này libor xitôzin
hoặc Collection hồi ấy tôi đọc nói chuẩn
không có hành động gì đó để làm
có khá nhiều đại khái là có vẻ vài bạn ở
kia có vẻ biết qua level rồi cháu là mấy
bạn ấy thì đang đợi mình dậy nâng cao
hoặc cả đang đợi mình sai dưới đó rồi
bắt bẻ à
khi video dạy về Vario thì bắt đầu từ
buổi nào nhỉ đã chỉ ra từ uống chưa có
thử vừa hôm trước Cài đặt đây ở trong
đại thái ở buổi Bố hôm nay được ra thế
này cho chị đến nay thôi thôi tôi sẽ
hướng dẫn mày ông về cụ thể xem
a free
Motion
Paris ở tôi phát âm đúng mà qua chưa có
ai đọc à
Vậy mày sao thế này thôi
buồm xong rồi sẽ làm nốt về toàn bộ là
sửa xóa sửa xóa được ạ ngắn thôi nhưng
mà tôi nghĩ bố mày quá tải thôi à
Thôi để tạm cái gì nhỉ Mấy ông trả tôi
sẽ đầy cốt này lên cho mấy ông chủ nghĩa
miếng sẽ toàn đấy hội 18 phải thay đổi
Okay đây sẽ là maria này
great và I read ra thế
này ok
để thay đổi ngớ face
à à
thế hả Đợi thì chính xác là nó không tất
cả Phai đâu Anh sẽ bỏ qua hay pha này
có
phải lại ở đấy mà
cho
tôi cài thêm cái clip mà
gì tôi chả biết lên đây cả lót hay không
thì như là không thì vậy
em cố tình bể cá lóc lên nhỉ Nhớ như
không đẩy lót đây mà chỉ đẩy cái này
thôi à lót là được tự động tạo ra mà nói
cho chúng nghỉ à
thế hả biết thêm sửa xóa mà đỡ đòi đi
thực tập
Lắp
con bơ vơ trong hãy nhớ không cần mà
ngồi thường hay ít no cái này mà đúng
không
a
nhớ đúng là tôi nhớ cái này phải noi rồi
sẽ tại Từ vị đo này
ừ ừ
có phải như bị lỗi nó có con hình chị
hơi say à
ăn kẹo đi
Ừ chị chị mặt hoặc cứ đẩy được không có
chậm nữa
hết
nhờ mấy ông tải phải lòng tôi về hơi sai
đấy thì nhé à
à à
Ê mấy ông đẩy Nếu không tải file lock
của tôi về mình phải xóa file lock thì
để mà chạy còn bây giờ nó mới cập nhật
lên đấy ạ
à à
ừ ừ
âm nhạc nên đưa hả
ở chỗ làm tôi nhớ không cần mà không
Đã lâu lắm rồi không làm này tụi chẳng
nhiều đó hãy tôi cứ đẩy lên mấy ông mấy
Nếu mấy ông cu kéo tôi về mà chạy qua
mother không được cái béo phải xóa cái
file đó phải đi rồi chạy composer
install lại cái đấy tôi nhớ là phải như
thế
Ừ Ok bữa mày chắc thế thôi Cảm ơn các
bạn Cảm ơn các bạn đã giúp đỡ nữa chắc
cuối bộ cuối buổi rồi nhưng mà mình trở
chưa trả lời được câu hỏi cha để sang
buổi sau nhé buổi sau này có thêm nhiều
thời gian hơn với sau mình sẽ tổng hợp
lại thêm nhiều câu hỏi nữa các bạn thắc
mắc gì Các bạn bình luận hoặc inbox mình
để mà mình trả lời trả lời không phải
cho mỗi cho các bạn nữa mà trả lời cho
cả những người khác nữa là sự Các bạn
thấy có vấn đề gì đó còn Thắng Bắc hoặc
là khi cài đặt có vấn đề gì đó thì các
bạn cứ
cứ nhắn tin anh mình kể cả các bạn giải
quyết được rồi nhắn tin mình để mà biết
đâu các bạn khác bị dính thì thì mình
cũng cùng giúp đỡ và biết đâu cách giải
quyết bằng trợ các bạn nó lại chưa tối
ưu lắm Mình sẽ giúp đỡ đúng không nghe
các bạn đừng có ngại thì nhắn tin nửa
đêm mình trả lời nhé á
ha ha
Anh thứ mấy à ra
à mình dạy 357 mà các bạn cứ theo ba năm
rồi nhé
ở trận kết thúc nha à